Test test
What's new in
Android Accessibility
1, 2, 3.  3, 2, 1.  We're ready
to start.
>> PRESENTER: Hello, everyone.
Can you hear hear me?Hello,
everyone.  Fabulous.
Tsaran.  I am an Android
accessibility program manager.
decided to spend the next 40
minutes of
this conference with us learning
about
and related
work we do with Google.
access environment can empower
people
disabilities to be productive
and
their lives.
organization, there is over 1
billion
disabilities in the world.
That's nine 0s.
over 50 million has difficulty
doing simple tasks.For example,
some of us take for granted a
glass of water or walking out of
the favorite restaurant or
listening to a
conditions.
For other people, these tasks
aren't easily achievable.
to change that.
millenia, humanity has been
developed
tech gadgets.
I will give you a few examples.
noble prize for this one, fire,
clock,
creating to improve the quality
of our lives.
some people, this is just to
improve the their lives.
disabilities, these gadgets,
this new
advancement made it possible in
many live their lives.
completely blind could not do my
work at
without assistive technology or
tools that help me to do very
basic life.  You know?
So in this case, again,
technology is
superimportant and today, we
would like you about some of the
technology.
low logic conditions where you
were
something or how about a
(inaudible) were trying to read.
long to pick up and read.  Many
things, right?might remember
discomfort and
circumstances.
discomfort and frustration to be
rest of your life.
people with disabilities, it is.
like this.
amazing power to change, if not
all of
certainly a lot of these things.
actually create some of that
technology.know something about
technology at Google, right?We
create that technology.
technology, we feel like we have
you
purpose so we can tell you about
things we create.Over the last
year, we've been working
creating some of the new tools
to help
disabilities, but also create
new APIs
more access age   With that, I
would like to invite
to you to kick off our marathon
and to
about well, where is Brian?
Here goes Brian.Welcome, Brian.
everybody.
My name is Brian Kemler and I'm
a on Android accessibility.
our new accessibility services
and the make them possible.
how we're innovating in this
space.
Android P to make hearing
conversations
easier.  Listening is difficult.
field with no background noise
and a
ears, but the everyday reality
is we
noise.
In fact, unwanted sound is one
of the common environmental
problems.
annoying, but it prevents us
from
colleagues, friends, and loved
ones no well we can hear, most
of us can relate
following acoustically
challenging situations.
trying to listen to a caller in
a loud
Listening to a presenter who is
too softly like me right now.
noise and boost the signal on
your
would never miss the
conversation?
sound amplifier.
accessible service that helps
user focus
world conversations using only
an and a set of headphones.
personalized levels to optimize
their
experience to the current
environment.
sliders for loudness and tuning,
over 100 audio presets in the
background.settings can then be
independently
ear, adjusting them provides
ambiient
improves ambiient sound quality
in a
scenarios including enhancing
sound in
or far away spaces.
somebody who speaks softly,
tuning --
TV to a volume that's
understandable and for everybody
in the room.
briefly explain how it was built
uses
dynamics processing effect.
effect is based on a four-stage
signal architecture.  Stage 1 is
pre-equalization.
think about the pre-equalizer as
a
to adjust any audio frequency.
and everything in between.
compressor.
stone of the processing effect.
sound and adjust down loud
sounds to better listening
experience.
post-equalization similar to the
first allows to you fine tune
any audio frequency.
Lastly, stage four the limiter
prevents
gain above a developer
designated thresh
prevents loud or unwanted
noises.
doing a number of demos and a
deep dive
dynamics processing effect and
sound at 3:30 on stage 5.
want to learn more.
we're doing to make Android
easier for
mobility and dexterity
challenges.
we're going to do a little
empathy exercise.
ask everybody to take out their
phones.  All right.
I want everybody to take a
screen shot.have a purpose.
Take a screen shot, please.
you have done that, I want to
you do it
want you to do it with just one
hand.
Screen shot.
Screen shot on your phone.
one hand, is it?
this is their everyday reality.
with tremors or limited hand
strength.
simple tasks such as holding the
phone, hardware buttons or
performing gestures
difficult, painful and time
consumeing.Accessibility
service, accessibility
accessibility service to make
common
easier for users with physical
disabilities.
alone, this is a population of
over 75 users.
Accessibility menu simplifies
the functions.
lock screen, take screen shot
and volume
directly to accessibility
settings instantly.
Further, we designed it with
very large targets located at
the bottom of the screen.
facilitates reach ant for those
with a or limited reach.
landscape mode.
on top of our accessibility
framework.
new APIs and lock screen.using
it today.
over to Patrick to talk about
vision.
>> PATRICK CLARY: Thanks,
Brian.  All right.Hello,
everyone.  My name is Patrick
Clary.Product Manager on
accessibility at
very excited today to announce
for the
time here at I/O a new app
coming to the called lookout.
who are blind blind and low
vision.
for them where it requires help
from others.
the users might be entering a
new space first time.  They
might not know if other people
present in that space.  They
might need assistance.
If I need a chair, reading the
office another example is when a
user is cooking.
might need assistance reading
the recipe different
ingredients.
leverage a users Smartphone to
make the space and are thes more
accessibility to
who are blind or vision
impairments.
of lookout as a personal guide
that sees
and speaks items of importance
that it the environment.
this ask what they will see.
four different modes and that
launch
work and play, home, scanning,
which is
long form text and experimental.
to actually specify the activity
they're
in and fine tune lookout to
provide more results.  So after
selecting the mode, a user
be presented with a live view
which will
items of importance as they're
detected.
profiles one of our testers who
is an
San Francisco and describes the
impact
piece of art that we can walk
on.
to experience this new thing.
I am a theatre and art
instructor.born visually
impaired.
impressionist painting.
working with my supplies and
they don't up where I want them
to be.
scissors.
12 o'clock.
have a physical experience with
art and observe it.
to watch or listen instead of
witnessing or doing.
>> PATRICK CLARY: So that gives
you idea of the type of
experience that provide.
areuson a massive experience.
their Android device on a
laniard like
perhaps on a shirt pocket.
the user.  If the user is
cooking, they can engaged in
that activity without having
their device and interact with
the screen.
wearing the phone, Lookout
provides helpful hints.
To facilitate this, we designed
a set of controls.
user can knock on the device to
begin
that Lookout provides and they
can do like cover the camera to
pause
the fingerprint sensor to change
different modes.
works.
So first Lookout will collect
live around the scene of the
user and then
series of machine learning like
bar
people are present, detect
objects and scene.
The next thing we do is score
these
based on a personalization model
and the user has chosen.
relevant and important items to
the user.important because you
can imagine in a
scene, there can be many things
we can however, we only want to
tell the user important things
based on what we know context
they're currently in.
note that we do most of this all
on the
that you can use this app
completely and
internet connection.
and low vision that harnesses
the power learning to provide
relevant results spaces around
them.
for users in the U.S.this
summer.
trust the testers.
out, go to Google.tester.  You
can come to our sandbox to be a
user as well.
talk about what we're doing in
the cognitive space.
>> MAYA BEN-ARI: Thank you,
Patrick.  Hi.
I amMaya Ben-Ari.
(inaudible) operating.
you work on the screen and the
text will
be read
aloud.
User can simply select text
using the
or in the picture and the text
will be and read aloud.demo.
For that I am going to go off
the stage.
going to open my camera.Here you
go.
this is the regular camera.
accessibility button.
button here in the corner.
And next I'm going to select the
text >> Select to speak with
those CRs on Android today.
Please try it out.
clicker.
data.
We'd love to have your feedback.
Android framework.
that the device are built O.
users can interrupt with the
touch
standard UI or even here the
sounds that are producing.
ways.
First one is developing APIs for
apps services to make.
range of audience and second, we
are accessibility features into
the framework.
enable developers to make their
app more accessible.The first
one is adding a pain title.
me start on what is a pain?
the window that is visually
distinct for
is visibilitily distinct for
users and like a window changes.
can see here in the quick
setting and
determine when panes on the
strength had updated.
accessibility pane title.
automatically notified to
changes to the pane.
user get more granular
information about
changed with minimal input from
app developer.
please do add a title to your
pane.
attribute so developer can mark
whether heading inside their
app.
for apps with text heavy views.
user who cannot view the screen
without the whole text.
Last API is we add the ability.
basically -- the last API is
setting forcible.
grouping of the contract of that
content.
example, let's say you have a
sports and
insure that the number
for the users who cannot see the
screen.
can use screen reader focusable
to group the content.
updating our documentation for
and grouping.
accessibility section in
developer.android.com.
features coming to the Android
framework.
the one is adjust vibration.
for users
innovation as some user find
animation distracting.
So we basically just added a new
setting those off.
launched the volume see
accessibility short cut.
basically to toggle on and off
services, you need long press
for three volume keys.
based on the feedback.
settings that you can toggle on
and off color correction and
coloring version.
second one is we reduced the
time to
seconds to one second after the
initial activation.
testing for accessibility and
its everything we built into OS.
the accessibility services in
the app
we want that Eco-system to be as
possible.
manual testing and automated
testing.
we found the combination of both
can better coverage for your
app.
different testing tools and how
those
integrated to cover
accessibility to accessibility
issues.
testing.
understand how your products are
used by users with disabilities.
need to turn --  talk back or
switch your app because you want
to be in the
user to feel how it is to run an
service; however, we are aware
that
takes time and you cannot test
for every you make into the app
and for that, we
provide -- there is also
automated testing.developed
Android accessibility testing
also shortly called ATF to
quickly
accessibility issues early in
the development cycle.
ATF is an open source library
which we
integrated into express end and
testing
accessibility issues.  ATF 3.
detail.
accessibility testing framework.
report and accessibility
scanner.
pre-launch report, we're making
it even
get accessibility tests results
by
directly into the developer
console.
what is play pre-launch report?
automated testing solution which
calls multiple physical devices
and detects developer can fix
before reaching their end users.
Including recognizing crashes
and
APK publishd to the Alpha and
Beta channel.
play pre-launch report also
include tests.
This is yet another example how
we
our core accessibility testing
library.
your app as in this example.
This is a cooking app.It will
launch accessibility tests
contrast ratio, touch target
size, missand so on.
opportunity to fix those -- to
fix those
their app launches and make
their app
which is an app that suggests
framework.
accessibility scanner discovered
more
accessibility in apps.
accessibility scanner.
A new version of accessibility
available today with additional
such as traversal order for
screen elemental.
suggestion and finally, we also
allowing
threshold for contrast ratio and
touch target size.
So to download accessibility
scanner, go to G.co.So to some
of the section, we talked
testing and we showed a number
of tools automate testing.
incorporate manual testing and
automated testing.
So please do try out the
different tools
develop the testing strategy for
your app.  Now another vital
piece of the puzzle
that said, I will hand it off to
Melissa about user research.
>> MELISSA BARNHART: Thank you,
Maya.Melissa Barnhart.  I am a
researcher on Android.
Now that we have gotten a sneak
peek on
services coming in Android P, I
would
about the role of research and
role and development process.
research?
research focuses on
understanding user needs and
motivations.
understanding the impact of
design on an audience.
best for users, but often times
we don't.
is truly the expert and by
seeking experiences.start to
challenge our assumptions and
perspectives.
Why do we do user research?have
heard the stat that 9 out of 10
but you may not know that the
number 1
failure is lack of a market need
for our product.
So in those situations, people,
design products that look for an
audience who interested in using
them.
for the opposite.
validate your ideas and inform
your
Hopefully you're thinking great.
when do I get started?  The
short answer is now.User
research involves a set of
along your existing product
development
helping you make decisions at
each stage.methods like field
studies, interviews competitive
analysis can help you
area of technology and uncover
opportunity areas.Once you have
decided what you want to
have a prototype, methods like
cognitive
throughs, usability tests or par
design exercises can help you
make decisions.  Once your
product is out on the products
like log analysis, diary
can help you evaluate its
performance.
have a lot of time or
experience, that's okay.
take a few hours and talk to a
few users.
Nielsen of the Nielsen norm an
Group
results come from small
affordable studies.
I would like to show you how
Android
research to rim prove our
accessibility offerings.Let's
take the example of talk back
feedback.
Talk back, Google screen writer
uses by default.
we wanted to know why.
off while others leave it on?
where vibration is more or less
useful
pattern or intensities of the
vibration difference?  Good
research starts with good
questions.
perceptions of vibration
feedback, we user interviews.
questions with vibration
feedback.turn it off?
of vibration on your phone.
or just right?
participate ants needs, we
prompted them
vibration feedback across a
range of Android phones.
So the tasks added a usability
component study.
In the research, we validated a
real for vibration feedback.
feedback provides availability
in noisy environments when they
may not
hear spoken feedback on their
device.that the more distinct
the vibration more useful.
wanted the ability to adjust
vibration
according to their personal
preferences.
Android P, we're giving greater
control over vibration feedback.
to their accessibility settings
and decrease or disable
vibration.beginning.  We will
continue to make improvements
this area as we further
research.
and resources to help you going
forward.
>> VICTOR TSARAN: All right.
for the importance in user
research in decisions we make.
few more announcements, could
we.
like to announce that Voice
access and
service that helps someone with
use their Android phone
completely
Voice just simply issue Voice
commands, is graduating from bet
A.
research, development,
iterations, we're
ready to launch it and give it
to you.
this summer, with new UI
enhancements, a
assist ant immigration and by
assistant,
Google assistant just to be sure
coming
Google assistant UI and more
improved overall.
So look out for Voice access.
is we decided to package our
that you commonly find built
into an
into a single package we call
Android
Some include talk back and for
people are visually blind and
vision impaired.
that allowed people
just demoed a few minutes ago.
manual that Brian also showcased
earlier.to come.
accessibility suite our other
services, not just talk back,
will be discoverable in the Play
Store as well
become a platform for new future
services we will be developing.
about you a little bit.  Right?
it.  You built a lot of the cool
stuff too.
evening, we announced Google
Play awards.
like to give a shout out to few
been working on stuff or apps to
make better and more accessible.
First our winner is
beam my ice.
people who are willing or
excited to give them help.The
way the service works is that
know?
blind or who needs help requests
it by themselves as a person who
needs help
getthentication and then pick up
the
and then they can help somebody
in real time.my eyes.  Check it
out on the Play Store.
open says me.
It is a lady known to some
people with
us in various Google I/O events.
the solution is it allows people
to
Android device just by looking
at it.  It's amazing.
Check out open says me and the
link is
mention is we really, really
care about gain.an important
aspect of computing to be and
independent, it is just as
important
Zealand is audio game hub half
they have
an experience for anyone to be
able to games with their eyes
closed.
on your ears and you play all
kinds of funky games.
I will not name them, but I hope
you go Store and check them out
for yourself.
resources.
We have the accessibility
scanner.
find all of the best
accessibility
anvoid development, excuse me
user research.but not least, we
have lots of sessions explore
here at the Google I/O.
opportunities for you to meet
us, for us
so that we can together create
more accessible and inclusive
Eco system.coming here today.
>> PRESENTER: Good afternoon,
everybody.  Good  afternoon.
Hello, hello.
and I lead the  firebase product
team.  Thank you for joining us
today.   We're so excited to be
here.
over an overview of firebase,
highlight
year and also talk about ways
that
firebase can help you across the
different stages of app
development.
When we started firebase, we had
a simple vision to help
developers built
come a long  way since the early
days of expanding the platform
from  being a
broad app development  platform.
And while our platform and
community
on helping mobile app teams
succeed.  And we do this by
providing a platform
key problems across the
different
stages of app  development from
helping
with  Google infrastructure like
Cloud firestorm and functions to
helping you
your app with tools and
insights like performance
monitoring and crash littics
grow your business with Google
analytics  and remote alike.  So
whether you are building a brand
app or looking to extend an
existing app, we want to help
you solve these
more of your  energy towards
your users and running your
business.
keynote earlier, we have seen
incredible momentum.  We now
have over 1.
firebase every month including
many global  partners that you
may recognize.
you are trusts us with your apps
whether you are a sole
developers or working in large
teams. committed to  helping
companies of all sizes to
succeed.
So you may have  heard earlier,
we  number of updates last year.
We  released four new products
and
our own internal learnings and
tools, but most important  and
most valuable of all based on
your feedback.
many developers is data privacy.
soon take effect.  So to  help
developers succeed under the new
regulations, we have  updated
of service to include a data
processing  and security terms
and have worked hard
to meet compliance needs with
many
privacy and  security standards
like
you are building with world
class data security and
protection.
firebase products work  and see
them in
and hear from  some of our
partners.
a developer team of  only 3.
this scale  without firebase.
So we use firebase to take care
of our
notifications.  Our app
continues to grow and we're
focusing more on stability and
now we're starting to
investigate how  firebase can
also help us there.
No one wants to use it from the
nice  user interface.
time and helping us  pinpoint
the root cause.  It helps us to
prioritize.
and then you can fix the crash
with the most users.
time to concentrate  on user
growth. firebase.  Now  we're
able to run smarter campaigns
that drive deeper  engagements.
increase in the usage alternate
back
>> Mobile games, user retention
is one of the toughest
problems.  When we heard about
firebase
we  wanted to see if people
increase retention by targeting
the  right users.
success by serving  those who
predictd to the turn we saw a
20% gain retention.
a fantastic partner giving us
scalable  easy to use
infrastructure.
>> We can drive engagement.
thanks to the power of  Google's
machine learning.
past partners and  all
you.
Growing user retention and
photos, you
can see how  firebase can help
you  stages.
and talk about each of  these
stages in
some of the  updates.  To start,
I would like to welcome Alex,
our lead  Product Manager
focusing
ways to use firebase to build a
better app.  Alex?  Good
afternoon.  Thank  you for
coming.
about app  development is just
how fast our industry evolves.
today compared to just a  few
years ago is really staggering.
More than ever,  building
successful
requires from developers to
carefully pick their battles.
grab off the shelf are make or
break decisions from  anyone
from the start ups to the
uncorns.
And one of the key goals has
been since its very creation to
empower
build better, more successful
apps
precisely by allowing them to
make the
infrastructure.  Excuse me this
is something  that I experienced
first hand.
I  spent five years building and
growing a start up that was
powered by many firebase
products.
built a realtime  collaboration
out.
We built all our sync engine
fully in  house.
infrastructure was incredibly
difficult.  And the time we were
spending doing
would be better spent on
focusing on
the core  user experience of our
product.
That's how we  started using the
firebase realtime database.
within a week of prototyping
with  my
a product and decided to
refactor our whole lab with the
database.
of the best engineering and
business  decisions that we made
as a start up
go faster and it helped us focus
on features that matterd  to our
users
that  essentially wasn't core to
our business.
And to me, that is  what
firebase really is about.
Of course since then, firebase
has brook a much broader
platform.
Firebase developers have
evolved.diverse than ever.
In a typical size of  firebase
teams  rapidly.
So today, one of  our core
focuses is
to adapt to make firebase just
as
of the size of your team or the
steal  scale of  your app.
That's why we build apps that
are  everythingo northeastic to
scale.
Going forward, you will  also
see us
that help you  better monitor
your infrastructure and test
your code and in
secure apps.  So now let's talk
about some of these
exciting updates that we have
for   developer tools.
Firestorm that stores  and
synchronizes
app data at global scale.
is NoSQL that am addresses some
of the toughest problems of
dealing with app data.
firestore allows to you access
your data
removingd need to build a proxy
layer between  your data and
your app.
to  your data as it changes in
realtime making building rich
interactive apps much, much
easier.
today
--
caught  firestore is also a
strongly consistent replicated
database  that
of queries than the predecessor
and  all those new queries have
the
with the results sets, not the
data sets.  What that  means is
that you won't be
and building  your back end
every time
you have ten extra users.
industry leading database
systems like table and mega
store and now spanner.
knowledge to give you a
powerfully
simple database to serve your
useers
if you have used  Cloud
firestore already, it won't come
as a surprise to
of these users are also using
functions in their workflows.
Cloud Functions which we
launched  year, let's you
automatically run back
end  code in response to codes
in AGDPS requests.
users  all over the world using
functions to build deceptively
simple workflows.
use case for us is the  Hamilton
act.  In particular because
their usage is so  spikey.
start a new lottery to sell
tickets,  millions ever users
Connectality the
of requests in a very short
period of time.
CloudFunctions automatically
scales
human action or intervention and
Hamilton only pays for the
resources
massively over  provision.
new features based  on your
feedback.
for calling  functions.  This
make integrating back end
functionality  into your app
much, much easier.
in our tooling, which was a very
popular
improvement has been the
expansion of
the ability to unit test your
functions before you deploy
them.
catch the problem  early on
before they hit production.
added new  monitoring tools to
Cloud functions.  This make its
easier  to test and
to production.  You can  keep
tab on any errors in your
functions and track your
functions
latency and memory usage.
When we say  that firebase
empowers
than just scalable
infrastructure.  We want to help
you  with tasks that
either  authentication.
It is currently being used by
hundreds
millions of users every  day
over 80
million people sign in to an app
using firebase  authentication.
you  signed in.  So these are
new sign ins.
with the digits team from
fabric, we
introduce
d   have seen to make sign in as
To  that end, we just released
passwordless sign in.
essentially just click on a
button on
your app and then click on the
link. remember.  You have one
less thing to cause friction in
your sign up.
these addition  into fire a base
UI,
the open source library
providing  UI flows.
on I/O
on I/O S.
You heard earlier  today,
machine
learning in AI are a huge focus
at Google.
fault that machine learning has
the
potential to unlock  so many
interesting challenges.
to make sure  that all
developers have
easy access to the power of
machine  learning.
launching ML Kit into Beta
bringing the power of machine
learning right into
and I
I os.
It suspect phase detection, bar
code
scanning, image labeling and
land mark detection.
They let  you build ML powered
experiences without needing
extensive
background in machine learning.
For those with advanced needs,
ML Kit
Tensorflow light models and
serves  them through Googles
global infrastructure.
models and evaluate them on
device
without having  to bundle the
model with
the app. this  example.
Let's take a look at disco, a
partner
who  integrated with ML Kit.
that enables  creators to
transform
photos with powerful editing
presets.
can be difficult to select the
best pre-sets for an image.
were able to build a
recommendation feature that
automatically recognizes
order to  suggest the best
presets.
For example, if the creator
added  a
ideal portraitor or presets.
Importantly, all the subject
matter wrecking onnition is
done --
is done on the device including
user  privacy.
over the next  upcoming months
and years.
more about  Tcheck out the
session on machine learning and
mobile  devices tomorrow at
3:30.
how it is easier to  build your
app if you use firebase.
want to learn  more, be sure to
check
out our session on 9:30.
I will turn it over to Kris  I
Kristen.
Good afternoon,  everybody.
of the  fabric team a year ago.
The goals of fabric even back
when  we
developers build their  apps,
understand their users and grow
their
businesses just  like fireface
base.
And I'm excited to be a  part of
it.
We found that 42% mentions
crashes or bugs.
reviews mention speed,  design
and usability.
between app  quality and
customer
satisfaction and retention is
undeniable. help.  Over the past
year, we have been working to
make a number of improvements
improvements so they're ready
for the  largest and most
complex apps out there.
some improvements.
over the last year was  having
in GA.  They're  best in class
crash reporter.  We are excited
to share today  that
app developers keep their apps
stable under 3 billion devices
world wide.
to help so many of you build a
better user  experience.
this so you can seat  trail of
events leading up to a crash.
them bread  crumbs.  In fact,
bread crumbs is one of the main
reasons  that our partner we
to try out.
Wetransfer  is a company that
helps
users share files easily to stay
in  the  while working.  They
have 40 million  active users
that share over 1 billion files
every   it's critical that each
one of them
goes off without a  hitch.
goal and maybe an  obsession
with
getting as closa 100% crash free
as possible.
achievable, they have a help
metric  of 99.9%.
If it ever gets below that, they
stop
fix crashes.  Bread crumb shows
the actions that a user  takes
leading up to a crash. so much
easier.  And the team no longer
needs to figure out how to
produce the problem  can be a
lengthy and  frustrating
process.
has been a game changer  for
them.
While 100% crash free is
audacious goal, we  are hope of
it can
hoping it can help.
you  have already used and the
crash is affecting a large
percentage of user base.
team and select  the channel of
your choosing.  We have many
more innovations  to come.  So
stay tuned.
We're super excited about the
future
of crash litlittics.   The
product will continue to be
until September,  but we
encourage to you try out
crashlittics and oup grade  to
it today.
last year, we have battled
tested the
STK, we're excited to announce
it is
Along with this comes a few new
exciting features.   We have
heard feedback that there is
lot of useful data in  our
console you can slice and dice
by things like
attributes, but we have heard it
can be  tough to be the most
important issues   data.  Today
we're announcing the addition of
the new issues  speed.  We do
the digging for you. will find
it at the  top of your
performance monitoring console
dashboard
issues you should be paying
attention to.
You can also dig into that issue
and
We're also now collecting more
metrics  out of the box than
ever before.
and network request, we now have
data on slow and frozen  frames.
information  automatically for
every page on your app.  Between
custom  traces you set up  our
out of the box metrics,
performance monalitorring has
your back
experience out in the wild.
Now, one  of our partners Swigy,
is
in India.  They started using
performance monitoring  about a
year ago.
STK on their  app, they realized
they had a problem.
First impressions  last forever.
diagnose the issues  that were
causing  down.
Those  fix over time.  Swigy was
able to make the start time
12X on I/O S.
They saw an  increase in daily
orders.  These type of increases
really  matter
you have over 350,000 orders
every day.
puzzle.
platform.  In  that spirit,
today we're expanding
Firebase test lab to  include
I/O S.
and virtual devices  that allow
you to  and OS versions.
With the addition of tesla for
iOS, we help you get on a  high
quality state
before you even release it  into
the app store.
One of our partners Spotify goes
to   insure that each and every
one of the
users  has a great experience
when the user is streaming app.
They  have end to end tests they
set up every night.
Before  Firebase, they even
built  homegrown device farm.
They found -- whatever time they
found was hard to maintain  it
and scale  as well as found that
some of the tests
would often fail unexpectedly
and they
that they trusted.  Spotify
decided they no longer  wanted
and  testing infrastructure.  So
they turned to Firebase test
lab.
immediate insight to where tests
fail.   They have long-term
access to test  pops up.
Spotify loves the scale ant and
reliability of test lab.
in  test lab, is they
experienced a 2X increase in
testing  throughput.
confidence so they  can stay
focus on what's important to
their business
to fans around the world.
We're  excited that test lab is
lab is across the platform. to
be an early tester, go to the
Firebase console or  use this
URL to get on the waiting list.
device lab and want to  see it
in
right out the  doors right
there.  To hear more about how
you can
transfer swigy and  Spotify did,
we have another talk tomorrow
that focusing
on stage 7.
is improves  management and
growing a
but there is  more to this
story.  To hear more about this,
I would like
on stage.  Grow your users and
increase
management with Firebase.
Christen.  You get  ready is to
launch your app,
important area  that they focus
on.  Growth.  This is a problem
that's  personal to
to joining Google, I was
building consumer mobile apps
like many of you.
we had a successful launch.
Had over  5,000 5-star reviews
until
only used our app for about 10
days and then  disappeared
forever.
new  downlet's every day, the
number of
daily active users on our  app
was not growing at all.
that retention and  engagement
are really hard problems to
solve and a
doesn't translate into a
successful business.  As we
talked to other app teams about
solving these problems, we heard
one thing  consistently repeated
about the growth process.
experimentation.
You can rely purely on
intuition.  It is  more
effective to run an  let data
drive  product decisions.  With
Firebase, we built products that
of the experimentation process.
First you observe what users are
doing inside your apps. make a
hypothesis about how to improve
their  behavior with respect to
your business goals.
test  that hypothesis by trying
a new product and experience.
And  then you analyze the user
response.
In Firebase, we're  building
tools to  scale this process.
You can  iterate quickly and
watch new
your business.
for Firebase which help  you
observe user behavior.
understand where  your users are
coming from, what they're
engaging, how often
how much revenue you are
generating.
Now  with Firebase, you can
always see
afternoonp and last year, we had
the
ability to  see anmyselfd for
individual users.
view  and streamview.  Now we're
excited to give you the ability
to level up and see aggregated
for all apps of  your project.
If you have an I/O S version,
you can
and are the metrics are trending
across your business.  This
means you can now analyze data
levels.  Across all your apps
for an individual
app  and even an individual
user.
visibility  in the user behavior
is critical because to drive
both, you
find segments to ultimately make
a guess on how to improve the
metrics.
and Google Analytics help with
you this segment segmentation.
can segment users on  what they
have done in the past. Firebase,
you  have an additional way to
segment users by predicting
their  future behavior.
of looking back what they have
done, you can ask them to look
forward on what  do.  Using a
combination of audiences and
predictions, you can target
users to drive a better outcome.
Firebase  predictions and we
launched
expertise and machine learning
to the Analytics dat from  your
apps.
it forms future  behavior.
Out of the box, Firebase can
predict
make purchases and which will
turn.  But if  you are tracking
conversion of
machine learning models can
begin to
predict like listening  to a
song or sharing photos.
we have made  predicts on 4
billion app users.  So Google
analytics and  predictions
segway users that might be
underperform.  They give you
actions to take so you  and
improve the health of your
business.
You can personalize the product
config maybe to help convert a
user.
Or send a  highly relevant
message to
to  bring users back into the
app.
control the behavior  and
appearance of  updates to the
app store.  This is really
important because we
not only takes days away from
valuable engineering resources,
but users also
their apps.  If you use remote
config like  marketing copy, the
size and color of
or  even the layout and flow of
the app, ask you tweak the
values -- you
instantly to users.   Now
another powerful aspect is that
on Google Analytics audiences
and Firebase  predictions.
Maybe you want to incentivize
users by  them a discounts or
how about changing the theme of
your app to be more receptive.
built to  provide personalized
experiences and keep users
engaged and
Another action you  can use to
optimize your business is
Firebase Cloud  messaging.
right  message to the rights
users to
app  and keep them engaged.
Whether using API or console, we
give
were sent and  opened.  One
common practice is send
messagings
your app in some time to improve
retention.   We can proactively
reach out to users  to  turn.
This is a powerful tool because
it allows to you  intervene
before it is  you the best
chance of improving retention.
Now as we mentioned before,
whether
remote config or Cloud
messaging, you want to test
these actions and make sure
improving your business before
you expose  all of your users to
them.
So AB testing let's you use data
to drive your product
decisions.
You define the various
and you have  randomly
distributing your user base to
the complex analysis
variant is achieving the best
results.   AV testing make its
simple.
secondary goals so that you can
insure that a winner  is not
only improving
retention.  Once you verify the
results, you can result
experience out to all of your
users.
use Firebase for  their app.
would receive an  apcurrinsey to
win prizes and make the game
more enjoyable.
models and most publishers, they
didn't have the
time or resources to dedicate to
this.
Firebase AB testing and remote
config,
they were able  to use the
console.
received the  promotion, another
group where users were loved the
promotion  3 and finally a group
that  would only see the
promotion if there were
predicted to  turn.
the system found was a 20%
increase in retention  rate when
showingthe  to  turn.  Really
amazing results.  So we just saw
how Firebase  helps  process.
Google Analytics let's you
observe what users are doing in
your app and  based on past
behavior.   Firebase
predictions, you can find
they might do in the future.
Once you found  segments to
improve,   various actions.  You
can personalizethe product with
remote  config or highly
relevant  other users with Cloud
messaging.  Most importantly,
you can do this in a
safe, low  risk way byes using
AV testing.  If you are
interested in  learning more
about how Firebase can help you
your app,  check out the session
tomorrow morning at 8:30.S a lot
of  new features coming in
Analytics.  So I encourage you
on do that as well.  That will
be 5:00 p.m. tomorrow.
it over to Francis to talk about
what is up for  Firebase.
I am super excited about the
future of app developments and
the  ahead.
As  you  you have seen from some
of the developments, across
Google  we're
the technologies to enable
developers like you to shape the
future of app development.
exciting part for us is what all
of you have  built.  Last year,
I am on a team of
a sign language translation app
to help hearing  disabilities to
better communicate.  because not
only did it help their quality
of lives, but  also for the
community around them.
inspirations like  this that
motivate all of us in Firebase
to work hard and  helping you
succeed.
ahead, we will telephone  to
deepen into
to to help you  solve key
problems.
Further more, we'll be expanding
to web experience on the web  to
help you scale better through
Google Cloud
advancements of ML to help you
to do more.  Our  mission is to
hip succeed and be
platform available  for
everybody in
the world while we made good
progress.  We  are just getting
started.
inspirations from all of you.
us shape the future of Firebase.
On behalf of the  Firebase team,
I
you and I  look forward to
meeting many
of you out in the sandbox after
this or
Thank you so much.
Per-for-
Per
>> TORI BURMEISTER: Hi,
everybody.  I'm Tori.
I am a Product Manager  working
on actions on Google.
first built, this we  previewed
this
talk, the feedback we
universally got  tips.
So we're adding two more tips.
excited to be working on
actions in
next step in the  evolution of
computer interactions.
and received the list of blue
links.
It opened up a wheel new world
of
exploration.
I also remember when I became
fully
dependent on my mobile phone
checking
the  weather, finding friends in
a crowd.
It really changed the  way I
lived.
actions on Google, I'm  really
excited
really  changed the way we
interact with computers.
in the back, we lost  the
monitors up here. please.
evolution in  computing.
on Google platform  and we are
here to show you not only being
part of the next  at T. actions
on Google is the  developer
platform for the Google
assistant.
your products and services by
the assistant.
With over 500 million devices
running
a great opportunity for you.
We're not here to tell you how
to
scratch.  There are  other
sessions covering that.
of you can use to build great
actions.   And when you build
great actions, not
users, but it opens the doors to
get your actions  noticed.
Throughout this talk, we're
going to  two  tools.
First, the actions on Google
console or sometimes
affectionately known as the
console.
administer your actions.
Second, dialogue flow.
build your conversational
actions and  includes a lot of
natural language
for making great actions.  Let's
dive in.
We  bucketd the tips into three
categories.
how you  make a great action and
avoid
-- this is how I get your
action to more users.
design is what  delights users.
mistakes and  solutions to make
a great design.  Tip 1.  Make
your  conversation as simple as
but no simpler.  Do you  know
someone who talks too much?
Well, an action can too.
interact, keep it simple.
Users don't need every  option
upfront, guide them to the most
used  and then  make options
available if they asked.  Now,
we're going to  act out a
conversation.
will be playing the exciting
role of
an action and I'll be the useer.
>> SUNIL VEMURI: Welcome to
sounds of relaxation.
Are  you frying to sleep,
meditate,
think or reflect?
We have something for that.
Would you like to also include
ocean
waves
crackling fire,  wind or birds
chirping with that?
for five minutes, 30  minutes or
an hour?
to sit or lie down.   Are you
ready?
Here's your 30-minute relaxation
sounds with birds chirping.
That was tedious.
I'm  definitely not in a relaxd
state of wind after that.
simple and get the users
quickly to the delight. a look
at another  example that keeps
the conversation simple.
Which session would you  like
today?
>> So it's the end of the day
and time to wind down.
Just find a comfortable place.
Let me go back.
Don't  auto play it again.
Thanks.
user quickly to  where they want
to go.  In a conversational
dialogue, we  know
time another question is asked.
So  the fewer steps to complete
a task, the better.
engaged by avoiding less banter.
Tip 2.  Add a  person.  We want
simple conversation. also want
to  feel connected and
engaged with your action.
Developing a  persona or a
personality  then incorporating
it into your  action
really bring its tos it to life.
There are many types of pizza
restaurants.
York walk up where you  can grab
a quick slice and the local
beach side local spot.
to communicate in a different
way and
your  action can exemplify this.
you can draw users into your
action.  We'll do some acting
again.
and I'll be the  user.
What would you like today?
What toppings would you like to
add?right?  It's fine.   But I'm
not sure we expressed  our brand
or  who we are.  Let's try it
again.
What can I get  you?
What flavor do you crave?
taken this one a  little far,
but you get the idea.
is a local  surfer.  Personality
can't be avoided.  It's human
they were  to attach
and we're hard wired to look
for meaning and the things
around us.
with your action regardless of
whether you  think about it or
not.
and define it.  Well defined
personas also  increase the
emotional connection.
usage, retention and brand
loyalty.  Things to think about
when you are
state is the  usish going to be
in.  Are they looking to relax?
Are they  excited?
of that, what role should your
agent  play?  Looking at these
attributes, these are  options.
The first might be a teacher,
someone  who is patient and
helpful and encouraging.
a  friend might be playful,
casual and silly.
Whereas a  helper, you will be
to be  proactive and  succinct.
We recommend you define the
persona at
conversation around it.
It can  make a big difference.
Users can be  unpredictable.
that we don't  always expect.
In the case of conversational
actions,
you didn't anticipate.
Let's try  this dialogue.  This
time I'll be the user and Tori
will be  the action.
What size do you want?
you want?  A small,  medium or
large?  The grammar was not
robust.
The  action didn't understand a
common  of medium.  In  this
case, I said double.
Now, I don't know about you, but
I've
and you can ask for different
sizes in different ways.  So you
want your grammars to  handle
common variations that might
can't up.
Let  me show you how you can
approach.
flow,  there's a simple way to
do this.  First, training
phrases.
of the common different  ways
somebody might say the same
phrase.
So, for example,  can I have a
medium?
A double,  please.  You can
include all of these different
phrase section so that the
system will  understand that
Arizonas might ask for things in
different  ways.
Let's take another example.
Rain boots.  So there are many
different ways  might  say rain
boots.
It can be gum boots, galoshes,
Willies.
interfaces in dialogue  flow so
users can give their responses
with these kinds of  variations.
there's another part.  The more
examples  you give, the better
dialogue flow can learn from
because it does have learning
capabilities.
And it  can account -- it can
learn  has  expressed the same
concepts.
So more examples, the better.
timeout that illustrates  this.
Timeout tells you about events
in the United Kingdom.
screen, timeout is asking for a
day you'd like  to go out.
The user responds with:  I don't
know.
timeout recognizes the fray I
don't  gives a helpful response.
In  the second screen, timeout
again  or Saturday.  The user
respondd -- today,  tomorrow or
Sunday.  The user responded with
Saturday.
Common variations and things
outside
for.
Excuse me  And on the right.
The user was being clever and
they asked for something  funny.
So kind of like an  Easter egg.
Something to make your actions
more robust.
Users can  still say unexpected
things.
talk to each  other, if the
listener doesn't understand the
speaker, they   it out.  They
ask for  corrections or
rewordings or try to give some
hints to  forward.
Let's take a look at an  example
here.
event?
understand.  When is the  event?
When is the event?
But I'm sure you heard
something like  a computer.
This is hopefully not something
unfamiliar.  The action is
repetitive and It gives the same
response.
It's  not noticing that the user
is Ernestly trying to move the
forward.  So here's what we
recommend.
For the  initial prompt, you can
give that.
types of  errors that you --
that we recommend you handle.
When this  happens, you want to
if the  back on track.
We  recommend the first reprompt
to be what's called a rapid
reprompt.
same response or maybe a slight
variation, but don't go too much
further than that.
isn't giving something you can't
handle, here's  where we call
escalated detail.
more  elaborate and perhaps an
example of what they can say to
move the conversation forward.
that, stop  reprompting.  Don't
pester the user.
We find the sequence  works very
well. another type of error
that's  called no input.
This means the user didn't say
system didn't hear what the user
said.  Perhaps  they were
thinking about what
they got  confused by the
prompt.  Weren't sure how to
respond.
three stage reprompting to  help
the user along.  And with these
six reprompts, you are   way to
build a helpful conversation
experience  that helps keep the
user on track.
code  this.
In dialogue flow, you create
what's called a fallback
intent.
simply create an array  with the
three where I prompts, add a
counter and some  logic.
the right prompt and that's it.
Great  design and delight to
users.  Remember keep your
dialogue  short.
Make robust grammars that handle
common variations and synonyms.
no match  and no input.the
design basics.
Let's make it more fun and
personalized.
Einvolve with your user.  When
you have -- evolve with your
user.
conversation with someone,  do
you introduce yourself again?
it again?  Same goes for
actions.  Be there with  help
and options when
to the  simplist and more
personalized conversation with
your user.
So here's a horscope action.
If you  don't speak Portuguese
and you don't happen to have
Google  Translate  let me tell
you what's happening.  The
first time the user launches the
sign O. subbasses kept launches,
it doesn't and  simply reuses
the previous answer.  This is
great.
a much better  experience for
your user.
this could  be when the user
invokes the action.  You just
give them  their horscope right
away.
are plenty of examples of  good
personalization.  If you are a
food action, you can
vegetarian and focus on those
choices.
If  you are a fitness action,
remember
is that the user likes and use
those as the  defaults.
Now we'll take a look at the
code.
user  info API, you can get the
users
name, anonymized user ID and
more.
if it's the same user on
subsequent invocations.
There are also more robust
solutions  O off.  So hearing
the code, you can see  we're
checking if we have seen the
user before. we do the
introduction.
If we have, we attempt to
retrieve the horscope sign and
then continue on  the
conversation.
What we want you to remember
from
evolving  with the users is one,
get rid
intro if the user is  familiar
with it.  And two, become more
personalized as you  learn about
them.
already know.
>> SUNIL VEMURI: We have all
already
computer generated  text to
speech.
nice text to  speech.  But do
you know what's even better?
Media.
one to make your actions sound
awesome.
First, the media responds action
PI.
clips in your action.  Suppose
I'm building an action  that
plays famous speeches.
include  the actual audio, some
images and some controls.  Let's
give  it a listen.
for you.
Ask what  you can do for your
country.
Great way to include a little
bit of media inside of your
action. the API is  straight
forward.
Just give the URL to an audio
file,
hand it to actions in Google to
play the rest.
It's a great way to bring your
audio  users.
The second way is through SSML.
Let's say  I'm trying to create
a
action.   Let's listen to what
this sounds like with plain text
to  speech.
Welcome to the tear fig world of
the  imagination -- terrifying
world of the imagination. >>
SUNIL VEMURI:  Tori, did that
sound creepy?
change it and see how it  sounds
if I
manipulate the  Voice.
Welcome to the terrifying world
of  imagination.
there.down.
Now let's add  some sound
effects.
>> Come in.
Welcome to the terrifying world
of the  imagination.
(roaring/growling).  There we
go.  What a  difference.  Now
we're talking.
to play that  for you one more
time, but this time I will show
you the   to compose this sound.
Let's  take a look.  (
thunder)
(growling) (foot steps and
slamming >> Come in.
Welcome to the terrifying world
of the  imagination.
(growling) >> SUNIL VEMURI:
All right.  What we did here is
use two  features of SSML.  Par
and prosit. you fine tune  how
the computer speaks by changing
the pitch, speaking rate  and
volume.
unique to access on Google.
Let's you play multiple sound
layers
audio and mix that with your
text to  speech.  With that, you
can make great sounds
for your action.
To further help you make great
audio environment for your
sound, we have a
with over 1,000 sounds including
ambiient sounds, sports,
Voices, Foley and many more.
to you include  sounds into your
actions.  Tip number 7.  Adjust
to your  device.
mentioned the assist ant is on
over 500 million devices.
Smart speakers, phones, watches,
Chromebooks, cars, TVs and with
the
assistant  STK, device makers
are
the  time.  When designing for
multiple guyses,
Sometimes it's Voice  only like
a Google home.  And with new
smart screens,  there's a
touch.
Sometimes the same  device falls
on different parts of the
spectrum
content like their driving or
the volume is  muted.
when designing for these.
Let's take an example of a surf
report O.
home, the report  needs to be
presented with just speech.  So
in this example,  the whole
is verbal and through audio.
Now that  same one on the right
is with a screen.
verbal presentation is a bridge,
but now there's a  visual
presentation that goes along
with it.
we  encouraged you to use the
rich visual presentations on
devices with screens. bottom, on
the bottom  right, you can see
the choices are presented as
can tap on them instead of
having to
speak  on a device with the
screen.
is  straight forward.
Using surface capability APand
some  conditional logic.
more about this  topic.
Fortunately, there's a whole
talk
about it Wednesday  at 11:30
called
actions for the Google assist
ants.
Beyond smart speakers and
displays.
are working putting  them in the
hands of users.
want to try  things out with a
smaller audience before you
launch to a  birth audience.
just releaguesd a new tool that
let's you test with smaller
audiences and  with it.  You can
do an Alpha release.  Your
action  goes through a limited
review. get early  feedback on
your action.  Give it out to a
small test group  and
of the Alpha releases is  that
the
review process is much shorter,
within hours.
test it with users and iterate
very, very  quickly and get that
feedback you
releasing to a larger audience,
you have gotten through all  the
bugs and design issues.
is doing a Beta  release.  This
is intended when you are near
version or near stable  version.
Test this with a wider audience.
typical approval for actions.
But there's  an additional
advantage
you  take an action from Beta to
public.  So that way if you are
trying to time
marketing  considerations, you
can keep it in Beta and when you
are  ready for
flip the switch and make it go
live  to the public.
tested it and  launched it, it's
great to see what happens. many
users  are coming back?  Or how
many users are there?  How many
are  coming back?
they encountering?
For  traditional metrics like
traffic,
views you can use to see these.
Retention like  a cohort
analysis is available through
chat base.
base  is a tool that you can
integrate with your action to
get  keeper conversation
Analytics. about some  things
that are conversational and
Analytics, let's take
well conversational  analytics
and this is called a session
flow.
takes most often.  The green
paths are  the ones that your
action handled.  The red are not
handled.
a usish says book a  hotel, that
was handled.
feedback  Twasn't handled.
Now, when we talked about no
match
tip, here is where you can see
how often these no matches
happen and where
addressing these.  Both dialogue
flow and  chat base
include a session flow view.
drill down, you can see
transcripts including the
individual steps a user went.
led up to  a potential problem.
So you can try to address that.
To  recap.
the next level and  increase the
engagement. the user.  Add
sounds.  Account for actions
running on different types of
devices.
with screen and some not.  Test
it with smaller audiences and
tools here to see what the users
are doing.
built your awesome  app.  You
want to engage your users and
many more.   Tip 10.
Reengage your users.  During
normal interactions  with your
users to opt in to receive
updates using two subscription
models.
Google pulls an update at a time
spes feed by  the user.
The second is push notifications
where
actions can push updates when
appropriate.
These work on  the phone even if
you  Android app installed.
Now with cross surface
notifications coming in to
Google  assist ants, you  able
to reach users on speakers,
smart
displays and other Google
devices.
This can keep you up  to date.
Here's an example. what it looks
like when  they're getting the
update.
As well as a notification when
there  delays.  Great way to
reengage.
If you  wanted user to get daily
up using the actions console.
The second way is in your web
hook and your code.
a new register update  object.
You can put in arguments here
horscope sign and  then the
frequency.
tip of the day or a surf report.
can be a great way to reengage
with
your users, but  they can also
be really annoying.
be careful to  make it relevant.
So use personalization.
of the whole league.  Be
descriptive.  Users will receive
the title and the  notification.
the content they're receiving
and
don't just list the name of the
action.
users.
Make sure the information is
relevant to  them or don't do
it.
Tip 11.
We're working hard to  make sure
all
And there are  three main ways
to get discovered.
The first is the  assistant
explorer directory.
to the assistant.  Make sure you
come up as an  option. the third
is is action links.  Your hyper
links  to your action which
you can add to any surface.
discovered.  Make it good.
We check each action and the
higher  quality, the return
rate, health and ratings, the
more likely we'll highlight
your action. the design
principles and the developer
docs to help guide you.  We have
some great stuff out there.
that will help.directory.
It's available  on the web at
assistant.google.com/explorer.
because we see that 30% of our
third-party  actions are getting
through it.
So when a user  is browsing, you
want to make sure you get
discovered.
option are contextual
suggestions.  These  relevant
suggestions are based
as  the time of day or location.
The second is dynamic
categories.
new, what's  trending, what's
popular
and now we have editorial pics.
This is a new feature with
campaigns.  You now know that
high quality is the
featured in the assist ant
directory.
To trigger  more naturally in
conversation, use built in
intense.
It allows actions to trigger for
relevant queries that are more
general.
taxonomy for actions across all
Google surfaces.
parses the user query and
passes it as structured data so
developers don't have to.
general intents much is more
natural for users  and this way,
users don't have to use your
action name.
are tell a joke or start  a
calming activity.
flow, you can select  the built
in intent and then add in
parameters that can be  pansd
into your action.
these intents available so you
can gift,
understanding of what your
action can do and we'll be
rolling out hundreds
more in the coming months.
So the third way to get
discovered is action links.
They're hyper links that point
your action.   They make your
actions discoverable
from any platform or  surface
and allow
to engage directly with your
action  irrespective of how they
found your link.
Websites, social campaigns and
more.
It's really  simple to set up
action links.
actions  console, Pudge inner a
URL link and give it a title.
And  then share away.
Be helpful everywhere your users
are.
We're  launched in more than 25
We  recommend engaging with this
global audience as soon as
possible.
countries and  languages.
and  multiple languages.
English, French and German.
And here  we're going to show
you how
localize an  action using a
localization library.
The first thing to do  is create
a locale's directory.
file for each locale.
In this example, it is  EN-US.
Then within the file, you create
a
constant for  each string in
your action
along with the string.
for  each additional language,
you create a new JSON file and
use  the same  strings.  There
are  many translation services
that can help with this.
you use the I18 and node library
to do the  hard work.
Here you're going to configure
the I18   and set the locales
you want to support the wear the
translation files
Then  when the conversation
starts,
you're going to set that
specific users
I18 object.
Finally,  throughout the
conversation, you use these
don't dance  instead of
statements.  Is this greatly
simplifies the complexity of
supporting multiple languages.
want to insure that the work
that you
have put into  designing and
enhancing your action pays off.
acquire as many users as
possible and
keep them coming back for more.
>> SUNIL VEMURI: There are so
many more resources here  at I/O
to help you  learn more about
these tips.  Look for sessions
marked for assistant
a few for you.
We have  sessions that talk
about how
to design for smart displays.
and Gains.  You can learn to
enhance your action  with
transactional capabilities, a
Excuse me there are sessions on
how to Celt  up the Alpha and
Beta releases we  and grow your
user base.  Finally, we have
office  hours and a
of the  team.
with hundreds of  partners
globally
We have seen a lot of these
challenges.
This list is  happend by this.
have given you a head start in
creating  great actions.
I look forward to seeing how you
in  the space and create cool
assistive actions.  Next.
5:00-7:00 p.m.
The Future of the andestroyed
App model
5:00-
:45 p.m.
The future of the Android App
model and
>> Hi, everyone. My name is
drew Knox.
I'm a Product  Manager on
Chrome's web platform team.
focused on make  the web and
easier
platform to build on, which is
why I am  here to talk about.
I may be a little biased when I
say
most amazing things  helps have
ever built.  Now, when I say
this, I mean the  web,
internet.  Now to be true, the
internet is  its
own wonder, but the web is an
open   that stood the test of
time.  And that's really
humbling to  me.
The web is on every desktop.
homes.  When we got through
collaboration and
we worked across individuals,
businesses,  even governments to
develop
anybody, but certainly
futureured by many people along
the  way.  I don't think there's
any other  like that.
play a leadership  roll on the
web.
context.  The  web strength
stems from that collaboration
and openness.
that we're excited to share
with the web community.  But
more than anything, it's about
discussion because once the web
community gets  involved, that's
really where things start to
matter.
Now the web's success carries
with it expectations.  As
technology is increasingly
part of users  lives, they're
expecting more and more from the
digital  experiences they
interact with.
service you provide anymore.
Everyone is in on  the game
these days.
want to keep up.
This isn't just a thought
experiment.
seen again and again that people
who put the time and  effort
into delivering
big  business rewards.  You
can't afford to stand still or
someone else is going to grab
the opportunity.
across the board, we see three
big
are ramping up rapidly  right
now.
Users.
Their sites to load instantly.
of users will abandon a site if
it takes  longer than three
secondings to load.
half your customers before they
have even seen your sites.
Delivering the load times is
really hard.only five seconds.
We know how hard it is  is to
hit the  target.  But the impact
of  getting the load times down
is very real.
that 20% of all mobile Android
page let's are  abandoned
because a site takes too long to
load.
20  %, 1 out of 5 of all page
loads on mobile is abandoned.
Now, the next area where user
are rocketing is  really
draconian.  In order to avoid
any negative user
to every input within 50
milliseconds.  No matter what
your site is doing, you
at 60 frames per second.
site's design is  tougher to
nail down
loading speeds, but  it doesn't
make it any less important.
improved by 60% when they
revamped the
quality and performance of their
website.
weren't enough, users
increasingly expect your
service to be accessible
everywhere.
of  their devices, their known,
laptop, TV, smart speakers, you
name it.
their services things  like face
eye book or snap chat.  This
leaves you delivering
quality while supporting an
evergrowing  matrix of
delivering platforms.
represent three big
opportunities for the web to go
further than simply making
things possible. want the web
to actively support you in
finding success with these three
key areas. your experience load?
How high  quality is the design
and interaction of your page?
can users find you?
ahead of us.  But web  steppers
have a leg up on everyone else
here.
well positioned to embrace these
kinds
new user expectations.
For example, PWA's show is 180
times
smaller than their
iOS  app.
of building high quality UX, new
users
convert three times as often.
worker or the purple loading
pattern give you unprecedented
control over how you deliver
your app.
push note fixing as, that let's
you
that can load instantly for
users.
And perhaps most obviously, the
web is cross  platform by
default.beginning.  Being
everywhere is built into the
web's DNA. how we do things.  So
building a PWA interest choosing
the web is like starting 100
meters down  track.  But  these
technologies, they only make it
possible to build  incredible
pages.
and flexibility of the
primitives I just mentioned, for
a lot of people who
out there and focus on
delighting their  users, these
can be unnecessary.
site more complex.
So we think that the web can do
more
to make incredible pages easy to
build  just  possible.
To started things off, let's
hear from my  colleague Stephfan
who we're doing
options for more  content
delivery.
like to talk to you  about
standards
working on right  now to improve
how to deliver content on the
web.
progression of sharing a link
with a friend viewa chat, you
get the link  the link.
We provide a nice screen shot of
it,  but wouldn't it be cool if
we could
content  rather than merely the
link?  What we'd like to be able
to  do is to
a web app just like  what Drew
was talking about.  This allows
for useful new  applications.
offline PWA installs.
What we  need is the way to
distribute
on it coming from exactly the
same place  that it was
originally published from.
notion is, we also need to make
sure we don't break  anything
while we're doing all this. want
to  break attribution.  We don't
want to break things like
integrity.
working on some  technologies
under the umbrella web
packaging.
is  currently being done as part
of the IATF standards
development process, web an
ITAF draft.  We think this
collection of technologies and
this approach is going
powerful new set of  primitives
which allows for simpler loading
architecture  in the use cases.
So the first  step along the way
to
getting web packaging is this
notion  of
Signed exchanges provide a way
to  associate shared content --
sorry.
its  origin in a way that's
verifiable and secure.
Assigned  exchange is basically
an  with a digital  signature
wrapped around it.  It has a
number of notable  features. the
duration of validity.
How  long this web package is in
fact valid.
mechanic anism that encourages
the browser to verify  at
appropriate
the most  current.
If the package has a problem or
if it
the user not to have stale
content.  You want to have
integrity.
within the scope of the digital
signature and  it tells us the
content   since it left the
publisher.  And finally within
scope of  this
the publisher.
This is going to come in handy
very shortly.
working on it.  So  there's
still stuff that needs to get
done. will have  things called
bundled exchanges.  They have
all the  characteristics of
+ they come with all  the
assets.  It is everything that
you wanted with
and about integrity.
world that has web  packageing.
aggregator,  for example.
And let's call it Google
Procrastinator.  You  subscribe
to a bunch of content.
when you want to procrastinate
and it
straight forward type of
application.
New, for a site like this, there
are
that can serve you very, very
well.
Now, imagine  we have a friend
Dave.  Dave is very
enthusiastic.
He tends to send us lots  of
links.
article.  Since  the success
rate is generally pretty good,
we will click on  the link. this
is what we get.  Turns out David
was great.  This is a
mind-blowing popular link.
server collapsed under the load.
Now, let's  imagine this was a
site
in  procrastinator.  Our server
could very well have already
downloaded a bundled exchange
the content that  belongs to
that page and it can then diss
play it forever  you.
super, super slow, but you are
still getting your content
because the
is all coming from the
procrastinator service.  No
matter what happens, the content
and although  this is served by
someone other than the original
publisher,  you
that continue is the same thing
that
the publisher originally sent
out.
no Connectivity at all?
Fortunately, it is  open web all
the way down.
It turns out we're using a
service
worker to render this and  the
one of which can be  the bundled
exchange.
So despite the fact the
originating
intrinsically support offline by
using  this offline, you get an
offline reading
handy when your Connectivity
fails or
you're in  aircraft without
Wi-Fi.
the  potential future of web
packaging.  But let me give you
much  more concrete example.
immediate example as well.
Now when app appeared on the
scene
deliver a user focused snappy
web experience  and if you were
at the state
on,  the median load time,
display time
of an amp page is still  very,
very low. work out so well was
the user
confusion caused by seeing a
page from a
publishers URL in the address
box.  We  look up chocolate chip
cookies and
the recipe and if we look in the
address bar, it still  says
Google.
com slash/amp.
web packageing, we  enter the
same query.  Chocolate chip
cookies.
is telling us web packaging is
involved.
We'll tap the recipe.  It's the
same thing.
up into the address bar, it
shows food network rather  than
Google.
to make  this happen, but the
user experience is one where
there's no
is very clear where the  content
is coming from.  At this point,
I would like to give  a
to our friends at foodnetwork
who sunk a lot of  time and
energy to enable this particular
demo. we also  like to you try
this for yourself.  It wouldn't
be very  shorting if we kept
this to ourselves.
dive at the moment on Android,
there is
enable the exchanges.  The
Chrome  loading team has been
doing a ton of work to make this
happen.
If there  certificate tooling
exchanges and in combination
once you flip the switch, you
will be able to
and get a better  sense of how
this technology works.
in delving even  deeper and
web packaging, I  encourage to
you take a look at the spec here
on this link
than you will immediately  learn
what to do with.  With that,
back to Drew.
Thanks very much.
Thank you, Stefan.
About halfway  through or so.
So we'll power through. we just
heard  about how we're thinking
about making loading easier.
to make it easier to build pages
that
stay fast and responsive after
they've loaded.
about what makes this hard on
the web
today, I think  of an overgrown
jungle.  platform.
It's focused on back wards
compatibility for most  of its
lifetime.  Now don't get me
wrong.
the stability of your business.
lot of Gruff we have accumulated
along the way.  If we go back to
that person who wants  users and
get their business out there, if
you are  just going from point A
to
of best  practices and rules of
thumbna you need to keep track
of to  keep your page
successful.
video games.   Videotape games
track a bunch of  behalf.  This
allows theme have far more
complex experiences and
interactions.
with board games, you find
yourself spending a lot of time
just moving
rules are being followed.  Well
if the web  did something
similar to video games?
the platform aware of all these
rules and best practices  that
you keep track
on your needs  and goals, you
can ask the browser to manage
those  automatically on your
behalf?
lot of tools out there that help
track best  practices. will
continue to be vital.  They can
be  much more opinionated than
the bare platform which allows
to take further and give you
better performance games.
They can offer more holistic
the lighthouse  report.  But we
want developers to be able to
websites.  We don't want them to
have to commit to an entire tool
chain upfront.
that doesn't require any
configuration, that  catches
problems from the first line of
code you write.
apply lighthouse, your very
first score is even higher.
that, we think that  the web
needs to make the best practices
available
directly  in the plat form --
platform.say this.
Internal JavaScript framework
has best
the platform's API surface.
This means  things like removing
patterns that are performance or
security anti-patterns.
If  you use something similar of
used  used HTML.   They try to
get you to avoid certain APIs.
We found that  these rules make
productive because they  catch
errors earlier.  They also
improve the security of our
sites.
when we turn the rules on, we
reduced
cross site scripting
vulnerabilities in  75%.  So
we're eager today to start a
discussion with  the rest of the
web community. practices  that
make most sense for the web.
What's the best way to  build
them
into the web's platform?
big role.  Feature policy is a
cross browser
implemented in Chrome with
positive signal thes from other
browsers.
allows the browser to have
feltsures of the  web.
It allows attributes where we
can spes  Chrome should disable.
A concrete example shown  here
is this
You can see it on an Iframe, but
you
can specify this site  wide with
a
is enabling the HR policy
anyone who
tries to use the synchronize XHR
request will get  an error.
learning the  ropes and access
is old school.
We don't want to just  turn off
APIs.  It is half the battle.
We.
practices, things like images
must have
that's more than three window
heights offscreen.  We think
there are three areas that
fit for this.
First area we think there's a
lot  ever opportunity is images.
found  at 25% can save 250
kilobytes.
A median network connections  is
about
That's 5 seconds you can  give
back with essentially no extra
development work.
easier to find the kind of low
hanging
fruit  and tackle them
incrementally.
we  have been working on
recently.
The first requires all  images
to have sizes. the user
experience  from jumping around
as new images load and resize
the  knows ahead of time how big
those are  going to be.
modern image formats.   Make
sure you take advantage of the
decoding and high  compression
rates of modern images.
image down scaling.
a desk top  image on a mobile
device.
And finally, we have a policy
that
poorly comment pressed  images.
Now with each of these policies,
what
thes the policy is that Chrome
rend ares it in  inverted
colors.
at  what is going on, you can
immediately see the images that
need further attention.
the exact  shape of the APIs and
figuring out the best way to
bake the   so they're useful to
you.  But  we're eager for
feedback.
flags.  If you turn on the
experimental radio duct
features flag, you can get
access
formats  with the two other I
mentioned coming soon.
reducing payload size of
websites.
that accrues  slowly over time.
We want to help infrastructure
teams  across their website
automatically.   As each little
regression came in,
it before they need to do a full
site redesign.   We're
introducing something called
creates  an attribute that
allows to you limit the size of
each  individual resource type.
things like images  should never
be
larger than 100 kilobytes or
JavaScript   than two kilobytes.
Now, the  specificity of these
policies allows to you track
down   as they're committed.
But the per  resource
flexibility means you can set
whatever policies   most sense
for your site F. you're a
multi-media  site, you will
bigger  policies than a news
site.
about today is  animations.
ability to  specify which
properties
are safe to animate.  Now, as
site  requirements and browser
evolve, you can  fine tune which
properties you want to allow.
a policy that only allows
accelerated animations like
transform and Opacity.
no matter what is going on for
the rest of your  site.  Like I
mentioned before, this policy
behind the same experimental
productivity feature flag.
Okay.  So I just ran through a
bunch  policies.  If  you're
interested, you can try them
behind a flag like I  mentioned,
this link to find more precise
API documentation and
information on how to
development environment today.
What really excites  me is
because
value at  development time, you
can start using them and
experiencing  them  the flag.
Just turn them on  while you're
developing.  But most important
is that we want  to
hearing feedback on what use
cases we're missings  and which
policies are the most exciting.
go to  the Github repo and
express support for what matters
to you  most.
Now automatically tracking best
practices is  only part of the
battle.
is that the web  comes with a
lot of assembly required.  This
is great for  those of us who
and push the platform to  its
limits, but going back to that
person that's
get to point A to point B.  It
make its difficult to find  that
perfect library from a third
party.
trying to keep the size of your
site  payload small.
the platform has shied  away
from building my level
productivity features
easy to get wrong and anyone who
knows about  app cache will
probably agree.
of the run time even for pages
that aren't using the API.
Everything is global on the web.
if there's a way  to provide
more of
these my level features while
avoiding
call together is layered APIs.
Now, as a brief aside, it turns
out
a pretty good set of
characteristics for solving
this problem.  The features and
the modules are imported.
use and JavaScript has  no
special privileges.
fit your needs,  you're not left
with nothing else to use.  You
can dig in  and build something
use case.
It is really just  there for
your convenience.
web platform features  like Adif
or index DB. important twist
and that's they have to share
the same discipline as a
JavaScript module.
be imported and they can't do
anything that plain vanilla
JavaScript couldn't do.
necessarily mean we implement it
in JavaScript.   But they behave
Identically.
a remote  URL, you specify a
platform identified by using the
same  module import Syntax. the
feature shift with a  browser.
Now, layered API is because they
are
of the gate which is why we're
including a  fallback Syntax
built in.
the layered API, you get
graceful deg reigation without
feature detection and doing
anything special.
But on browsers that do support
a layered API, it is  a standard
lib, but
exploring.  So we  built two
prototypes for layered APIs.
infinite list  called virtual
list and Async local storage
API.
experimental productivity
features flag I mentioned for
policies.
we tried building something with
these ourselves.   So for any of
you who have tried to
the  HTML spec page that might
be a small group, it's huge.  It
takes a long time to load and
frequently staring at a  white
screen because it is loading a
lot of text all at  once.
see here on the left the normal
HTML spec  page.  Then on the
right using the virtual
API to load content as we go.
You can see that it loads  much
more smoothly.
incremental  loading view
recycling infinite list
implementation T.
library or write  anything
custom code.  This works right
out of the box.
to get the concept.  We are
eager to keep working with
browsers and the web community
to   that and the specific shape
of these APIs.  But  key to that
process is feedback from you.
look at  this link if you want
to find
out more about layered APIs  and
try  the features flag.  Just
make  sure to provide feedback
in the Github repo in the focus
of  all  and the best way
forward.
The last top they could we
mentioned
was getting  your content
everywhere.
platform team,  we want to make
it easy for you to offer one
definitive  experience.
portable, high quality,
interactive, even if the user
comes to that
than your top level URL.  We
want to make it  easy for other
services to embed that content
and all  its  interactivity
while preserving users privacy.
Westbound  packaging is a key
first  right?  The signed
exchange allows you to make sure
that all resources are
attributed to your site.
They  use any storage, any
partition
your resources into one easily
shareable package.
to allow  different sites and
authors to move seamlessly
between one  another.
fluid animations from one  page
to
another even if they're separate
domains.
embedded interaction to a full
page experience  without losing
any state of a user's action.
here  are still evolving.  If
this sounds a bit vague, you're
not  allowed.
peek or a call to get in  on the
action.  We have a proposal and
are interested
around it, but we need to hear
others  thoughts before we know
what it looks like.
in how we build something
between an I-frame and  a link,
something that sits
go to the  link here and join
the discussion.
and interactions,  getting your
content everywhere. are quickly
going to become stable stakes
for successful web  experiences.
make it easy to make this
transition.  We want to make it
easy for you to  web.  So this
is really just the beginning of
how  we can make user
experiences
how we can  foster content
discovery and composition while
making it   these experiences.
So if you  take two things away
today, the first is turn on the
experimental  features flag and
start playing  with some of the
things we mentioned.
to the Github repos linked on
the slides.  If you  have any
questions, Stefan and  sandbox
after the talk.  So you can come
up and ask us anything.   Thank
you very much.
6:00-6:45 p.m.
PWAs:  Building bridges to
mobility,
desktop and Native
mobile, desktop and know  Native
Per
Here are the links to more
information about the stuff we
covered  and please take  a
minute to fill out that
evaluation form.  The feedback
is  good. got it in there.
done.
>> Yeah T.
>> Should we get some caffeine
before we head over?
>> Why don't we use the
Starbucks web app.
Okay.  What would you like,
Pete?
>> PETE LePAGE: Can I do
a CHAI tea latte.(inaudible).
Back to the  order.  Excellent.
Let's go do it.  All right.
You don't have to clap that
long.  Sorry.
>> JENNY GOVE: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Jenny Gove and I'm a US
I  work on user experience and
web experiences.
Developer Advocate on  the team.
lots of reasons to love the
web.  It's the scale. users on
almost any  device.  And the
only thing they need is a
browser.
to share.  There is nothing to
install.
It's an open EKO*E system that
anyone can use or build on.
talking a lot about  progressive
web apps.
new set of  capabilities that
allow us to radically improve
the user
our users.
First, the experience  must load
fast and feel fast.
fast something loads across the
network.  But also how  long it
takes us to get
the screen.
The experience also needs to
feel integrated.
It needs to launch in the  same
way that other apps are launched
on that
guys device. same way that's
right apps do.  For example,
using the  payment
request API to make payments a
snap.
It should always work because
when it
loads too slowly, it breaks  in
user
experience and it really
destroys user trust.
bay area, there are areas with
poor cell  coverage.  And there
are people here in the U.S.
to use dial up to get online.
And world wide, more than 60%
of cell phones are on 2G
networks.
creating a reliable  experience
is crucial.
Engaging  experience starts at
the
a delightful  first run
experience for the user.  It
continues throughout  all of
your
so that they work perfectly
without friction.  An engaging
user experience uses the   web.
It is indexable, searchable,
linkable and  shareable.
The experience is timely and
relevant  it's  precise because
it counts for
users context and what matters
to them now.
on making your  experience
engaging, you
with  UX professionals.
Researchers and designers to
identify
those critical journeys for your
experience.
Things like asking for
permissions
the user first opens the  app.
There's no real to do that at
this point.
sign up and sign in at the right
time.
When  they're investd in the
task   something for them to
gain from doing so not only
something  for your business to
gain.
important flows to  get right
are
payment experiences that we
alluded to I  shaller. be quick
and easy and -- they have to  be
quick and easy and frictionless.
and not frustrated by that
experience.  I will be  covering
this more on
in  another talk called Google
Pay:  Best practices for
payment. and forms.  We talked a
lot about performance of forms
before and the user  experience
of
there is still really plenty of
poor  experiences on the web we
found out.
that was conducted in Europe on
400 top sites.
We found  that 42% of the sites
from  didn't show  the
appropriate keyboard for the
input type that was needed.
friction and that was  quite a
surprise us to.  It's the best
practice that has  been  long
time.
shouldn't it be walled a
standard practice?
All of these they should.  We're
finding that a lot of the time
getting them  right.
We also found that 27% of sites
didn't clearly  identify which
fields were optional.users.  For
example, the user might be
number of sales is they to fill
in,  when actually that's not
true.
to complete an experience that
is not applicable  to them.
Ultimately causing them to give
up entirely.   So it is critical
to make sure you are following
all the  best practices of
input type,  using features
appropriately.  We have a set of
principles  here we
conducting extensive research
that can help guide you towards
creating a more
So you can find those at that
link.
this whole ideaa fire.   Fast,
integrated, reliable and
engaging.
reliable experiences is service
workers.
are now supported in every
modern  browser including --
browser including safari and
Edge. support for service work
or back in
March and  the receipt update to
Edge   supported there too.
Browsish vendors are all adding
new
that really  enhance the user
experience.  Edge got push
notifications  and
stuff with the at home  screen
through their store.
and is working on the web
notifications  APIos.
And fare is also working on
those web   APIs.
at the very  successful PWA
launched by the team at
Starbucks.
capabilities and brings a modern
web
makes it easier to  browse the
menu,
customize and place an order or
pay for
All right.  So I will go over
here.
.  All right?
And then I'm  going to sign in
and if should sign in
automatically.
Pete is going to buy me a
coffee.
once in a while.
And here we're signed in.
And  then I'm going to add it to
the  here.  I will  add that.
Let me shut that app.
And here it's been added  to
home screen. progressive web app
here.  I  will launch it from
here.  Okay.
So now I'm going to order  my
coffee.
location  because it knows I
will be browsing and looking for
order.
I think I'll have a coffee.
Plans a cafe  mister.  Let's see
if -- there we go.
maybe I'll  go for an Americano.
All right.
So it ams me to have a  Grande,
I
a bit smaller.  Let's pick  a
tall.
I'm going to go for a splash of
milk.  All right.
a little bit of sugar.  All
right.
So add  that to my order and I
can
want it.  This is the nearest.
I will confirm the store.   Add
that to my order.  I got one for
you.
And let's  take a look.  So
there they are.  Actually, I can
check out  from there. leave
them sitting there.  We will
probably go and pick them up.
All right.
I was somewhere where I didn't
have a good connection.
So I will put this into
(inaudible) mode. this happened
to me recently actually.
I visited London, which is where
I'm from, the UK.
going to see a friend.  I knew
that Starbucks was on the way,
time on my hands.
I could actually browse the menu
here
and see what I wanted to order
on the way.
It's able to do that.  So I can
make good use of my time  I want
to do that.
So these  experiences extend
even to payment.
have a connection, say I am
visiting a  different country
where I don't have a
the store and I want to pay,
then Starbucks is also  cashed
my payment  the store  right
there.
So that Starbucks progressive
web app  experience.
And let's go back to Slides.
really paid off of Starbucks.
is by the number of daily and
monthly active users.  That's
more than doubled from their
experience.  So it is really
paying off.  Useirs  are placing
more and more user  web app
with the number of orders
growing by 12% week over week.
approach and made sure  this
worked nicely on desktop as
well, they're
the web app in order to order
ahead so
the drink is ready when they get
there.
Starbucks app has  been so
successful.
but if your  site takes more
than three seconds to load, you
have lost  more than half of
your users.
Tneeds to feel like it loads
fast.
to use place holder content.
You can see  here until the
actual content is loaded.  it
looks like things have started
to load to the user.   Those
great placeholders have quickly
by real  content.
And on fast network or when the
contempt has been
be aware of those.  Another
aspect is navigation between
pages. fast.
It never feels like the page has
a full  reload on the web.
the  network, but instead
everything
should be pre-cached and  ready
to go.
friction of sign ins,  Starbucks
makes sign in as simple as a one
tap thing.
new API.  (inaudible) is going
to be  talking
more about it in his talk called
Sign up  in  on the web.  So
check that one out.  You can see
we got the  app to home screen.
the phone properly.   I'm sorry.
That was my fault.  I was
responsible for that.
home screen prompt.  They can
add this to  their home screen.
When the user adds your
progressive
app to their home screen on
Android, Chrome automatically
creates an APK for
refer to a web  APK.  Your app
shows up not only on the home
in your settings.
So can go in  and see where the
permissions are.
being used and so forth.  Today
Chrome  automatically will show
when  the site is not already
installed.  The users interacted
with the site
it meets the  PWA criteria which
means that it's got a web app
manifest, a
(inaudible).  Of course the
easiest  way to test that is to
use lighthouse.
set up in the web tent if you
haven't gone over  there and
seen it where you
through  it and talk with folks
on the web team to understand
what is  going on.
tomorrow on lighthouse and  the
Chrome UX report that will go
into a lot more  use these
tools.
Today, before Chrome shows the
add to
home screen prompt, it's going
to fire a   install prompt.
This gives you control over when
that  prompt appears.
experience,  they don't want
that prompt to show up if I'm in
the middle  of ordering a drink.
the user to finish what  they're
doing
and then say oh, hey, add this
to your home  screen.
want to distract the order or
the user.
So in the default event  and
call prevent default on it.
Prevent default says hey,  don't
show up.
so that in a  moment when you're
ready to show it, when you're
like okay.
this to be visible, you can call
prompt on that saved event.
You can also tell when a user
has  your app to the home screen
by listening for the  app
installed event.
will  teleyou that yes.  They
clicked.
I want to install this or  crime
or
added -- able to  add it to the
user's home screen.  That's
today. prompt.  But it's
changing.  All  right?  Starting
in Chrome 68, Chrome is no  that
prompt automatically.  Instead,
you're going to  need to
prompt event.   Then trigger the
prompt by calling prompt on it
on that  saved event with
useer gesture.
To make the experience
reliable, Starbucks used workbox
with a
and run time caching strategies.
By pre-caching  their content,
they
that the app needed to run were
always there.  They wouldn't
have to wait for the network.
user uses the app  and they're
able to cache additional content
as they  navigate around.
what they allow users to do as
we showed earlier is you can pay
for your order.
about the users previous orders,
about the  nearby stores they
have gone to and their payment
details.
be available.
progressive web app  engaging.
so the users can  customize that
drink with many options
available.
fundamental details like the
navigation stack making sure
that the back bend does the
right thing.
navigate  step by step back up
rather
screen and also another random
page.  To make the experience
feel more
content specific to  provide
feedback to the user.  For
example, after clicking  at
order,
a toast letting me than it's
been added  to my bank.  As you
can see through creating a fast
reliable and engaging
progressive web
app,  Starbucks have put their
customers
where they are in the context
that they live, they work,  they
play to make
delightful  experience in order
to
So have we bunched that fire
Acrohn's  acronym in your head
yet? bad jokes.  I have a
couple more set up for you.  So
be ready.
working on building  their own
progressive web apps.
usings a  progressive web app to
make it possible for users to
ask  questions  and then provide
an answer  once they have
reconnectd.
It uses service workers,
background  push notifications.
By using service  workers, they
were able to reduce the number
of external
requests by nearly 50% and they
were
age to  reduce the number of
user
by  loading JavaScript by 6%.
So they saw a pretty good
performance improvement.
which is a  new way to create
and share hyper local stories.
It's all  built around a
progressive  app.  It's a tiny
fraction of  a Native app and it
has 100% of the functionality.
neat stuff with the media
capture APIs so you  can take a
picture or video and
and sharing is as simple as
sharing a URL.
And the Maps  team recently ship
a web ap.
They
Previously, many of these  users
were getting a so called light
experience
mobile in mind, but it didn't
take
advantage  of the new
capabilities that  to  offer.
The progressive web app doesn't
have
feature parody  with their
initiative app. around four key
user  journeys.
Again, see that bad pun?  I told
you there were a  few. were
really important.  First they
wanted to  make it easy for
land  marks so they can get a
sense of where they are.
They help  them discover new
places.
they wanted to make  it easy to
get directions.  So that they
could figure out  how to
And users  are using it even
more.
The new experience is seeing 20%
more
page loads compared to the
previous  experiences.
Targeting low end devices, but
the  to put that extra effort
into making sure that
everything was fast.
the  beginning by establishing
code size, load time and
benchmarks that can  every
single commit.
They use Chrome DEV tools to use
memory and performance and  test
it on
looking for any regressions.
They   needed it make sure it
worked  flaky  networks.  They
set a goal to be mindful of how
much data  they were using and
trying to  that in check.
Forever  users on expensive data
plans, they wouldn't consume too
much of their data.
progressive web app.
I've already installed it on
here.
that -- oh, I guess we should
come out of  airplane mode.
That would be kind of helpful.
neat things, they have that no
internet.  They give you an
indication of
You can see this looks like the
standard Maps experience.
It may not be quite as shiny,
but I  check out and try  and
find a place I have been once or
twice before.  Sports  page.
quickly almost instantly with
all  the information.  It has
that standard page view.
about the things that I'm
looking for.
And if I  clear this out -- even
the  places -- there we go.
It remembers placings that I've
been  to before.
page, that's all still  there.
It is cached in an index DB
table so  to go.  If we can
switch back to the  slides,
great.  With the previous Maps
experience,
focused to put as much Beta as
possible
into that  HTTP request.
CSS and  JavaScript and Htext ML
templates, stuff they might need
for
They wanted to have  everything
there so they can get started
right away.
web app, they have refactord the
code into  really super fine
grain modules
worker when they're needed.  So
unlike the  traditional
experience,
cod  that's needed -- code
that's needed T. doesn't have to
load  or execute that
code meaning
And the Maps team wanted to make
sure
reliably no matter what their
network connection was like.
To achieve that, they use
service
to cache the core app shell of
their app.
So they can eliminate the
network in that initial stuff.
how they were going to  store
the map tiles.
somewhere between  10 and 20K
each and you imagine as you pan
and zoom, you can  of them.  In
fact, you can load dozens  of
them by panning and zooming
pretty quickly. change
frequently.  Imagine new
businesses open and  close as
things changed.
Those map tiles are
So starring those tiles using
the
they wanted to  accomplish in
V1.  So what they decided to do
is use the  browser cache. in a
really neat way.
As each  tile is successfully
loaded,
an index DB table.
Later when the browser goes to
get it again, the service worker
regenerates
URL based  on the version
information
and is able to go back to the
browser cache.
the tile back from the  browser
cache again.  For things like
searches, directions
stuff, all of that is saved in
index DB.   That is always there
on the users   offline.
To help eliminate some of the
yankieness is  possible, and
reduce the
memory that's  used, they use
the layers panel in Chrome DEV
tools to
and remove them from the  dom.
That also shows them really
useful if you go into  3D mode.
context of your page.  If you're
trying to figure out what
It is one of my favorite ones
that I recently started  playing
with that's been around for a
while.
also  decided to limit the
amount of
transparency and buck shadows
that they have. the search box
you see up  there is a full
development.
In the normal experience, it's
a  that has the map tiles drawn
behind it.   They don't have to
draw the map tiles behind it or
anything.
One of the biggest  challenges
that
progressive web app  is the
storage APIs are stoned to the
origin.  And I didn't  realize
this.
Maps is actually served on
Google.com.
So that means it shares the same
but also search and Chrome's
default new tab page.  Any
service that Google serves is
They  have to be careful not to
step
on other folks toes.
tools is the clear site data
button.  It removes the service
workers, gets
and let's start from zero.
Of course, that  includes the
cookies.
what was going on, I kept
getting signed out of mail and I
couldn't
my cookies  signs me out of my
mail.  It was a pain in the
butt.
So we gave you a lot of
progression about progressive
web apps to mobile.
developments for progressive
web apps today.
of mobile has been  strong, we
mustnd forget desktop usage is
still growing
chart here.  This graph shows
that  mobile phone
has significant use in the
evening time.  Desktop  usage is
not evenly
when most  people are at work
and at their desks.
It's mainly lead by
productivity apps.
of the apps we use today
messageing
like slack and Spotifying.
be really important to use
because it gives them  the
confidence the app will be fast,
reliable and engaging.
built desktop hats  using web
framework that  embeds their
application in a custom built
web browser.
does today.
It feels kind of  redundant to
ship an entire browser and your
code given that   already has a
browser on that machine.
Not only  have you significantly
but you have to keep that
rendering stack up to date. and
more.  So you are  responsible
for your app and maintaining
that rendering  stack in this
case.
desktop -- PWA for desk top.
desktops.  And it also needs to
be fast integrated,  reliable
and engaging. me now I'm  sure.
That means they launched from
the same
place that  there was desktop
apps, but  run also in an app
window.
So they look and feel like other
apps on the desk top.
progressive web apps to  desk
top.
you today is on  Chrome OS.  But
work is already well underway to
support  windows and Mac as
well.
web apps through the Microsoft
app store.
at the FWA experience --  PWA
OS.
I will  move to this pixel book
now.
Let's go to Spotify.
will see here that it asks me if
I want to install the app.
So I'm going to say yes and -- I
can  install here.  If  you look
quickly and closely, you
will see it land on my  shelf
down here.
close that out and show you how
easy
it is to launch it as if it was
my
So Pete, I heard about the ban
tomorrow  night.  Did you hear?
I'm kind of excited.
Let's --  all right.
keep going.
the window.
demo is good.
So you  saw that it was -- I can
and see if it will  play.
You can see the install app is
gone here.
app and it is using the whole of
the  screen that's in the app
window and it's
that I can launch directly there
from my shelf.   All right.
Let's move back over to Slides.
Getting started isn't different
than what you are already doing.
like a whole new  class of apps
or anything like that.  All of
the work you  have already done
existing progressive web apps
still applies.  Service workers
make it fast and reliable.
push notifications to keep users
up to date.
They add to home screen criteria
as it does on mobile.
running in a tab, it is  running
in an app window. no tabs or
address bar.
It is just your app.
There nkow is window
organization.
make it really easy to
-- you have the  standard
maximize as
you would expect and on Chrome
OS, the   bar, it is themed
based on the manifests colors.
Speaking of the web app, I do
want to
you  future proof your apps by
adding the scope property.
It  defines the set of URLs the
is going to consider  within
your app.
If you leave that set of URLs,
it will
This is important.  In the
future, this is going to be
Within the app and menu, there
is that
app mernew that gives you the
URL and  you want  to get into.
into account building  desktop
necessarily  always apply to
progressive web app on mobile
devices.
to significantly larger screen
real estate.
Don't just put your content with
extra
use the additional space by
creating new points.   Some
applications benefit from that
wider view.
-- as it continues to get
smaller, I
can still see  the same content.
This shows me only the current
condition.
might show me the current songs
and the button needed to  change
the song.
responseive  design to the next
level.  When switched to tablet
mode,  these  window full
screen.  Depending  on how the
user holds the
device, maybe even the landscape
report trait.
responsive  design and that's
what matters here.
mode.
Responsive design is critical to
a success.
Desktop progressive web app
experience.
possibilities.
So  work with your design and
take a
approach for  break points.
There's a screen or not and
works
nicely with  those virtual
keyboards.
support for windows and Mac and
for all
support with functionality.
Them is the launch  icon to let
users know.
installed  PWA when the user
click on a link that needs to be
handled  by that app.
out for announcements on the
premium block that you see here
for updates and  it today.
So we have about a minute  and a
half left to cover the last
section.
I won't go that fast.  I will
cover the key  stuff.
out in another video.  We know
that  there are a lot of cases
where this makes sense.
to integrate your web content
into your Native  app.
Today you can do this using
either a
or  custom fab.
-- one of the things you want is
to be
have control.
Trusted web activities allows to
you oints great that  experience
powered by  experience.
It is rendered by  the users up
to date.  It isn't a mechanic an
torch wrap
and you put it on the Play
Store.
It can cause  some kind of
drastic problems.
design to Mike it possible for
you to use the investment on
your web app
app.  There are a  couple of
requirements.
They must be done as first party
content. it has to be yours.
You need to  add an intent
filter in
your manifest and you need to
pass  the
progressive criteria we talked
about earlier.
You  need to follow the standard
Play Store guidelines.to do.
Essentially two,  but we'll call
them sort of four. up a set of
digital  asset links and
that allows you to prove that
your
web and then create the
activity.
The  code here is we will get
this up
and details where they already
-- if
you go to G.
co,  all of the notes in and
including
to get  started on this is right
up there.  So that completes
this talk.
So  you can all get to the party
tonight.
progressive app works.
They are bringing a  more
convenient
and great ease of use to  their
consumers.
We're seeing how Google has web
apps
and how progressive web apps can
improve  desktop experiences
through careful design and use
of app  window.
you can  integrate your PWA into
your Native app.
focus on being fast, integrated,
reliable and  engaging.  They're
transforming the web on mobile
on  desktop.
three things, one go  check your
that before  prompt event.
Go try that and out of scope and
if
a look at trusted web
activities.  Thanks, everybody.
Thank you.